[Music]
so that's a perfect segue I've got a
whole bunch other names okay let's look
I put that aside sir because when you
sat down we immediately mentioned a
couple other people that I've done some
shows with from learn Liberty and Steve
Davies came up and I said to you that
when people try the number one thing
that I get asked is why do you call
yourself a classical liberal instead of
a libertarian and I've said a few times
that if I sat down probably with who
would you say is probably the most
preeminent libertarian thinker today no
yeah I would just give me somebody alike
yeah I mean so I mean I mean online mean
tend to be the economists who dominate
this conversation so Bryan Caplan who
you had on total weeks ago runs a very
successful blog Tyler Cowen
I put in that camp I mean so something
like Jason Brennan has gotten a lot of
publicity lately for his book against
democracy so I mean we were shifted out
of I guess we might think of being the
the 20th century libertarians Hayek and
Friedman and all these kind of guys and
we're moving into I guess a new
generation of a thought again tends to
be dominated think by economists but not
necessarily so so the question that I
get is well what makes you a classical
liberal as opposed to a libertarian now
I sat here with Bryan Caplan a couple
weeks ago and he really in my opinion
goes really far on that libertarian
route right but I fully enjoyed the
conversation and I don't agree with you
necessarily on some passivism stuff and
some open borders stuff and all that
that's all good but I told you that
Steve Davies gave me the best
explanation of classical liberalism so
I'm going to link people to two things
for now if you see David and whatever
you're going to say right now what would
it have difference between a classical
liberal and a libertine libertarian so I
mean classical liberal of them if I can
get my students to reproduce liberalism
is the political ideology of individual
rights and limited government if I can
get them to reproduce that I'm happy I
that tends to be enough for me but how's
that different than libertarian of
libertarianism also libertarianism is
relatively big tent so libertarianism
was in many ways it was a political
movement first as it were libertarians
include I mean Brian's an anarchic
capitalist I think yeah if we talked
about yeah he election or not so it can
go the Bryan Caplan van Arkel
capitalists
I mean a variety of different sorts of
anti-state social it's all the way up to
Bill well since I mean it's a it's a
relatively big ten in essence it's a
political movement that I think the idea
behind libertarianism seems to be
something like reducing both the size
and scope of the state so it's in some
sense it's a political project first in
it it tends to really want to resist
being attached to some larger moral or
cultural doctrine yes liberalism I
really do think that in some sense
liberalism was linked up to some
conception of the good life some
conception of rationality some
conception of a work ethic alright so in
other words what I think classical
liberalism extends a bit further down as
it were from the political than
libertarianism yeah in a weird way if
that's a flaw of both of them that
libertarianism became a political party
first so it maybe didn't have the
philosophical underpinnings of classical
liberalism classical liberalism which
was based in philosophy first maybe
doesn't have the root to began the
political party at least in modern day
America yeah so they I mean it's not
depressing I yeah that's an interesting
question I would say this I mean so when
we talk about classical liberalism I
mean this is this is the kind of the
this is a function of the way that we
talk about ideology so in other words
you look at Locke you look at Hume you
look at Smith none of these guys even as
they produce the liberal tradition none
of them knew they were liberals right so
another week we look back we said the
the the set of ideas the doctrines that
were produced by this general set of
thinkers this Canon will call it will
set the lines here with anyone within
this this way of thinking we'll call it
liberalism and there's there's many ways
in which I mean see take even people as
con illogically close to one another as
locking you mm-hmm
dissing they disagree very strongly and
on number of different things so right
so Hume is not a natural right there's
the Hume is extremely shy on the right
of resistance and all this kind of stuff
and yet I think we would we would say
that both of them contributed to
something looking back we call the
liberal the liberal project so
liberalism I think tends to be much much
broader much much bigger
than been libertarianism I mean I would
say that today both major political
parties about ten years ago was that
both major political parties in America
would sit within the tradition of
liberalism broadly understood though I
mean very few people are running around
today saying we ought to suspend you
know rights of due process you know we
ought to suspend free speech or
something like that very few people are
offering what I would consider to be
real alternatives to liberalism whatever
that whatever those alternatives might
be they might be theocracy they might be
communism I mean that's in other words
we seem to have and something settled on
the idea that individuals have claims
against the state that individuals ought
to be as free as possible and all this
kind of stuff and soui
many ways we're kind of working out on
the margins of that particular of that
particular view libertarianism seems to
me as a kind of a smaller political
doctrine within that broader thing that
we call liberalism yeah it almost seems
to me that it's the classical liberals
which I do think are the next political
movement here we should just hijack the
Libertarian Party I mean it's such a
freaking mess yeah why not just grab
this thing at least they have some of
the institutional and upright and and
grab that go who would you say are the
in American political history the
politicians that have been closest to
real classical liberals I think the to
the probably pop to mind for me would be
JFK and and New York State Senator
Patrick Moynihan yeah probably the most
- who else or do you even agree with
those right I mean in a little tradition
I mean so general I would say you know
that I mean the founding period uske I
mean so somebody like Jefferson - the
whole slavery goes I'm Jefferson at
least are good he was freeing the slaves
at the same place when he at least I'll
put it this way I mean he articulated
the ideas that would absolutely be
seized upon by somebody like Frederick
Douglass and Frederico saying listen you
know it is this great speech he gives
what to the slave as the 4th of July
where he says your founding documents
are great they're beautiful and yet at
the same time what could be further than
reality than your founding documents so
in other words I mean I would say that
just generally men men like Madison and
Jefferson these not only were they
consistent with what we think of the
classical liberal tradition but in many
ways they contributed the classical the
classical liberal project in the in the
20th and 21st century that bethod
tougher question so
I always thought that so I'm actually
I'm I grew up in a town called Marion
Ohio and in Marion Ohio we we have the
warren g harding presidential home he
actually he ran the Marion Stars a
newspaper in town I gave towards there
for years but Harding's idea of normalcy
so Harding was president after Woodrow
Wilson people forget that the Wilson
presidency was I mean I guess we were
reminded of this every once in a while
but it was an absolute mess we're
talking I mean just unbelievable
American casualties and a completely
pointless war economic catastrophe of a
number of sentient RT a called missus
actually where we get the word normalcy
the return to normalcy and so the he was
only president for a couple years he
died in also something it wasn't it was
a great president by any ones by any
stretch of the imagination but just the
idea of a restrained role of the
presidency the President as a kind of a
steady hand on institutions that I think
is relatively consistent with the
liberal tradition I think for me a
president for me a president becomes a
threat to the liberal tradition when
they see themselves as leading some kind
of movement as being in charge of a
vision as speaking for the people and
some meaningful sense this is very much
what the Progressive Era was about so
you see this in TR you see this in
Wilson the idea of the president being
in a kind of strange sort of way the
president in being a single person
popularly elected the president can then
be the kind of the voice of the people
and the president can you know carries a
big stick needed to deal with the
entrenched interests in the entrenched
interests in entrance interests in
Congress and big business and all that
kind of stuff I mean this was the
progressive vision and I think you see
you see a lot of that rhetoric today on
both both with Trump and that also with
Sanders yeah so Trump though is a
particularly interesting cases right
because he obviously is that he thinks
he's the guy in the populist and all
that and at the same time he doesn't
care about the social issues so there's
a nice classical liberal feeling of live
and let live there he's trying I think
you know even this regulation thing
where he's going to strike down two
regulations for everyone do it it's
gimmicky it sounds like a game show
right but but there's a nice
going back of the staff there it doesn't
sound like we're going to have a lot of
adventurous war all of these things that
I think are basically within the
tradition of classical liberalism but he
has that other piece so how do you have
you been him no one I think has a good
eye full holistic understanding of the
game
well maybe and I mean cuz in a lot of
ways he's there's very little of him
there right I mean you mean the the
classic line what Trump believes whoever
the last person he talked to was it last
persuaded him and I think a lot of that
is true I don't think he has he doesn't
seem to be terribly ideological figure
um I mean he he in some sense
intuitively grasped in the way that a
lot of demagogues historically have he
intuitively grasped in some sense what
whatever you want to call the people I
mean it was a very particular set of
people and we're talking about Rust Belt
Appalachian voters I mean the real red
states also I guess out west he
intuitively grasped what it was that
they wanted what they wanted to hear and
a lot of this didn't have anything to do
with policy positions a lot of it was
just you know listen these establishment
types have been screwing you over for
however long and I'm going to be the one
who comes up here and and does something
about it
I mean he was the ultimate outsider in
an age of outsiders I mean there is
something a little tiresome about this
constant you know we need outsiders and
watching to mean outsiders and watching
all this kind of stuff but nobody did
that quite as well as as Trump did and I
mean so just in the places that I grew
up in Ohio and LA my family's from West
Virginia I mean I could almost
immediately wants to begin talking I
could say that they're going to love
this mm-hmm
where they're kind of they're tired of
being looked down upon in all this all
this kind of thing now when it comes to
classical liberal Tricia my own view I
think that competent unmitigated
disaster from the classic liberal yeah
actually the regular I might say he's
gotta go I think he's maybe done
something that we can sort of tolerate
right but I don't think he has a
political philosophy no he well he
doesn't have I don't think it definitely
doesn't have a kind of a clearly
articulated political philosophy or
political ideology right but he's very
good at symbols he understands symbols
quite well the wall is a really good
example I mean the wall is not a policy
position will it actually curtail
immigration I see no reason to think
that it will most immigrants apparently
come over on planes they overstay visas
they do a number of different things
yeah
will they have any effect in other words
on this on this on this thing
immigration
an immigration itself isn't only policy
question the average person their view
on immigration is not informed by
statistics I mean they don't know that
net immigration from Mexico is negative
they don't know any of this kind of
stuff it isn't it there's it it is real
to them as a policy or as an empirical
question but they do understand insiders
and outsiders mm-hmm and they do
understand what the wall represents in
some way so the wall represents a
reaffirmation of the American identity
or the idea of America and in particular
it represents that reformation by
reaffirming the boundary between what is
American what isn't who is America and
who is not I mean there's a reason we
don't put the ball on northern border I
mean it's in other words the range is
very clear but Trump grasped that
intuitively he knew what the wall would
mean at some level it doesn't matter if
the wall ever gets built for for Trump
the wall was that symbol than he needed
to brand I mean it was just a big
four-letter word that he could sear into
the brains of every American and it
worked it worked tremendously but it's a
really good example the way that Trump
was able to seize on this language in
order to speak this language without any
of the other sort of stuff that you
would think would matter I mean you know
Hillary Clinton had policy positions out
the wazoo but I mean nobody wants
goodness yeah but nobody cares we can
probably a function of technology and
attention spans and all the rest of it
all right well part of it is I mean I
mean part of ated was Polly physique
policy positions I mean she wasn't she
wasn't in a variety way she wasn't a
great candidate but yeah I mean so for
me the troubling thing about Trump is
hardly to do with this idea of the wall
I mean in to the extent that in some
ways the cultural politics of the right
have crowded out any policy positions
that they but they might have so not
just the walls the regulation things
another example actually for the to
appropriate new regulation two of them
get scaled back so again it is kind of
gimmicky and there is this kind of
individualist libertarian conception we
don't want regulations including rules
all this kind of stuff and yet at the
same time
I mean it's gimmicky in the sense that
pretty soon they'll just figure out that
you they just click three regulations
right what won't work right there's a
math right here yeah and on the other
hand I mean so it's not clear to me
though that
that what libertarian the classical
liberals ought to be doing is just a
kind of a sort of whole scale reduction
in the state so so any you know a lot of
these you get these reports X number of
institutions have no he's not making
these appointments all this kind of
stuff these jobs aren't going to have
done it's not clear to me that in the
void left by whatever these institutions
were that whatever is going to come in
there is going to be conducive
individual liberty I mean there's a
sense in which when you know when chaos
is introduced when there's a certain
amount of disorder very rarely is it
that cut something like an ordered
Liberty as the result of that usually
it's whoever has the loudest voice twins
rum and so I'm afraid at this point I'm
afraid of the loudest voices yeah
and I'm afraid of the ways in which this
kind of brute force approach to scaling
back government is going to allow those
louder voices to enter into the fray
what do you make for the argument that I
basically by now I voted for Gary
Johnson very grudging you were the one I
was the one guy I should be judged
accordingly by the way I'm not you know
and I need a perfectly nice guy and I
have had him on the show and I've
chatted with him privately and you know
you'd be a great guy to have dinner with
but was a pretty pretty terrible candid
but what do you make for the argument
that I hear people say that Trump's win
for getting political philosophy for
getting virtually everything you said
here that it just shook the system in a
way that no one else could have shook it
so if you believed that we had a real
problem here if you you know between a
state that was growing and NSA and taxes
and whatever foreign policy and all of
this stuff that just seems to get bigger
and bigger that he was the only
sledgehammer tonight I think there is
some legitimacy to that it doesn't mean
that was going to come out on the other
side is going to be any better and you
might be right that it's just going to
bring on louder voices and that this
could be the beginning of the end of the
republic and all that stuff but do you
think that there's a legitimacy to that
line of thinking oh no I know absolutely
and be clear I mean needs to you now
we're verging into the territory of
stuff I mean I you know when I say I
think I think Trump is this I think
Trump is that I mean I want to emphasize
that this is what I think is that we're
talking about extremely complex systems
I mean I think it's very difficult
anyone who says they know what Trump is
going to bring about anyway
says they know this was going to happen
that's what could happen I mean is is I
you know either speaking from an
ideological position or it's just trying
to get clicks I mean so in other words I
don't in other words I have I have
relatively strong views about Trump and
yet I I still hold him weakly enough I
could be proven wrong yeah and this is
this isn't interesting this is an
intriguing line of thought this idea
that that the American that American
government had has kind of taken on this
kind of autopilot it only grows it only
gets bigger it never ever recedes it
never scales back and that the only
thing that could ever bring about the
scaling back would be a kind of
catastrophic moment right so in Trump
with in this case would be that you I
didn't the sledgehammer yeah so I'm
sympathetic to that to that view and
there's and if you look at history right
I mean you can look at a number of
different events kind of a great
historical tens they tend to be Wars
right or whatever that on the one hand
they tend to be terrible when they're
happening and at the same time because
they kind of clear out space for
innovation to take place they kind of
clear out space for people to think
about the way they live in new ways on
this kind of stuff they can actually end
up having a long term beneficial effect
and so I'm skeptical that line of
thinking but I could I could definitely
see how it might how it might happen i
but I guess I worry about the short term
in other words I worry about a large
scale war I mean I worry about this idea
of America being about walls I worry
about this kind of thing in the short
term and I worry that the that in some
sense we're producing a culture of the
right that isn't that it's going to be
hostile to individual delivery for a
very long time yeah I mean I worry about
all that stuff too and just as I said
all throughout the election his moral
compass I mean if this guy gets into a
Cuban Missile Crisis situation which way
is this whole thing going
one other pieces related to Trump what
about the cult of personality when it
comes to all these political
philosophies that we're talking about
that here we have a guy that it's really
based on that and not the political
philosophy how should we view that that
it's very warily I mean
I mean if I have to say their idea of a
charismatic leader right I mean is I
mean most of the great destructive
movements in the 20th century we're
letting some at some level by it by a
great charismatic leader and I want to
be super clear I'm not saying Trump is
now I'm not saying trumpeters Stalin or
anything like like this but at the same
time I mean we can see this I mean you
you I mean I'm not you I mean presumably
you have people on your Facebook feed
from you know that that watch Fox News
or do whatever and when you when you
talk when you when you go home when you
talk to people and there seems to be
this sort of broad willingness to listen
the the media itself they're reporting
stories that I have no reason to believe
anymore
that the you know the kind of the
mainstream narratives and I know from
the from the media but from the
universities that I'm getting from
Facebook that I'm getting from all these
sources I've no reason to believe that
these are true anymore these have been
in some sense the curtains been pulled
back yeah and I can see that there is
some big II the establishment right that
has been kind of feeding in these line
for years and years and now for the
first time right Trump was the one who
pulled the curtain back and I can trust
him he has access to all these things
after all he's president I can trust him
as an authority not only as an authority
in terms of the sort of legal and
political authorities that he's
entrusted with this president but I can
trust him to shoot straight in some
sense and so once you dig your heels in
a deposition you kind of close yourself
epistemic way off from everything else
that's bad I mean there are very few
examples historically where that is
turned out well does that show you how
far we've come I guess in the wrong
direction in a weird way because even
right now as we're taping this and this
is going to go up in a couple days but
as we're taping this this whole story
about Susan Rice broke and it's
unmasking of the names and all that and
immediately I saw on CNN they were like
three things immediately Don Lemon who's
been on the show who's a friend said you
know we're not going to give this any
credence or something to that effect Jim
Sciuto and other CNN guy said the same
exact thing and then I think a third CNN
guy think maybe it was John King saying
this is all nonsense something I'm
mostly quoting them but the more they
did that the more I was like wait a
minute there probably is something here
so that our trust in the Fourth Estate
now is so broken right that that adds
another piece into this whole equation
yeah
it's it's a it's a real mess in in some
sense it I think does it is a function
of Technology in the sense that what
Twitter and what everyone having a
camera in their pockets whether they've
allowed us to do is to kind of peer
behind the curtain in a number of ways I
think you can look at something like
police brutality in a similar sort of
way so I mean we always kind of known
that particularly if you were black in
America right the interactions that the
police could go south pretty quickly but
now that everybody has a camera that's
always on in their pockets when we're
seeing things that we just cannot
believe and once you see the frequency
of these sorts of interactions once you
see this the I mean the sheer injustice
of how easy it is for you know for for
those for you know for police who do
this kind of thing what how easy is for
them to get to get off and all that kind
of stuff you start to wonder how
widespread is this like how long is this
been going on I haven't known about this
in other words you begin to look at this
thing right you begin to look at
American police you didn't think this
institution which even ten years ago I
had some modicum of confidence and I
thought was a reasonable just
institution now you begin to think this
is just this is a House of Lies that
I've been told my entire life and weave
in with alternative media I mean we're
told the same thing so you're on The
Young Turks at some points the other
democracy now I mean just YouTube the
the way that YouTube offers alternative
narratives I mean you know we've always
had alternative publications Mother
Jones and reason all those kind of stuff
but now we have a million of them now we
have entire channels which are dedicated
Fox News being a good example which
which can see what themselves is
providing an alternative narrative to
what's going on and so suddenly right
we're not going to go back to or
whatever Walter Cronkite right up that
is I mean that was what was in some
sense true this was a kind of a common
epistemic world that we all lived in now
we're all kind of fractured and off in
our own communities that I think is a
real problem and I don't see you and I
mean for right now it doesn't seem clear
to me how that's going to be pieced back
together again how I'm gonna be able to
begin to start agreeing on very basic
facts was the ones the president
wiretapped
they're not right week it's almost as if
whatever happens over the course the
next six months will be unable to answer
that question in a way
that's I mean it's a basic empirical
question right and the hysteria machine
and outrage regime adds to that so it's
not just the the technology of it but
when Trump said that thing when he
tweeted that thing about the wire cap I
saw it and I didn't jump to comment
immediately because I was like let me
see what happened here now it turns out
that Obama probably did not order it but
something did happen and this is where
then the truth becomes subjective to
everybody because if you're only reading
Media Matters and Mother Jones or
whatever you're gonna get one thing
you're only reading Fox and some other
right with Breitbart or whatever you're
only going to get something else and
then we just said that I mean in these
publications no I mean they know what
their job is right so the thing comes
out and they're their job is spin right
their job as they listen this is clearly
this is the position that we must take
and so we must find the facts that
conform to this particular position and
you know whatever arguments whatever
kind of back flips we can perform to get
into this I mean all you know all the
all the all the better for us I mean
it's just going to people are going to
keep clicking on articles they're going
to keep watching the news and all this
kind of stuff I mean it so it is I mean
it's so in other words you're you're
right in that on the one hand it seems
like our kind of share of world has
become fractured but the people who are
doing the fracture they're very little
incentive to stop in fact they have
every incentive to keep fracturing yeah
keep saying that it's us and only us who
can offer you the truth about what
happened it's a no no no that's who can
offer you the analysis that's going to
that's going to cater to your to what
you want to hear anyway and yes I mean
that's ultimately I think that's the
other that's the other kind of part of
all this is that yeah we don't want to
hear like if you mean if you watch Fox
News you don't want to hear what they're
saying at Washington Post if you read
the Washington Post you want to hear
what they're saying approximating it's
uncomfortable for you
these are unpleasant experiences and if
we can you know ultimately I mean down
to the last click cater our online
experiences why would we introduce
discomfort yeah into our and this
actually goes all the way back Johnson
rappelling does rimmel describe this is
it's a painful experience that I'm depos
painful disagreeing with people is
painful coming to the realization that
you might be heaven forbid wrong about
something this is um this is unpleasant
yeah I'm glad you brought it back there
because so that's sort of sort of just
to wrap everything up here it's
of a nice bow on all this is there a
moment do you think in the last 20 years
that we got much worse at that because
it does seem like it's all gotten worse
and I don't know if it's just the
technology part I know that's obviously
a big piece but do you think anything
else may be culturally happened or
something in America to definitely do a
911 I mean I'm going throwing things out
there like do you think there was
something else for the most part I would
seem like a slow creep all right I mean
these it seems like it's all that the
dripping I it's a constant dripping drip
drip drip every morning you log on and
just kind of reinforces the the sort of
positions that you've already we've
already taken up and I mean that so that
that's interesting I mean for me the the
moment in which I guess the politics
became fractured in a way that I
previously wasn't aware of and I was
just I was a kid at the time but was
probably during the Clinton Pietschmann
scandal I for a variety of reasons but
it was the way it was the way that
Gingrich was able to organize resistance
against Clinton for the first time as it
were it was they adopted they adopted
this kind of outsider pose I mean Newt
Gingrich's real trying to describe
himself as an outsider the drain was
pacified I mean I mean it's absolutely
insane actually the guys name is Newt
he's a former Speaker of the House and
yet yeah drain the swamp is his
performance right yeah that is sick
for the first time I mean in that case
it there it seemed to me that there was
that these partisan affiliations that in
some sense the break was fundamental
that they were occupying different
spaces different worlds and that any
compromise between these two parties
would be viewed as as a betrayal by by
by the by loyalists now I mean it's very
very easy to say that no that's always
been the case politics has always been
that way look at Reagan look at this
look at that whatever but for me anyway
that was the fundamental moment which I
said these two groups something
something is I haven't colors up yeah
in other but again it was it was the
cultural politics that the right adopted
I think in the late 90s that I think are
that proved particularly pernicious and
not as if cultural politics are only on
that we only have them we only have
right culpable to both sides have these
things
but it was that point and I think the
Internet does ample find us to a certain
extent we're not interested in policies
but we aren't written symbols and we're
interested in symbols with cultural
cachet and when we talk politics now we
talk in terms of simple I mean bring
that let me just take something like
take a US soldier right so if you're if
you you know if you're on the right
you're tend to refer to them as troops I
support our troops right I mean for
whatever reason we've just sort of
gravitated towards this word troop
you just don't hear the term troops as
often I think in on somewhere like
Mother Jones they tend to raise soldiers
in some sense but whatever reason I mean
these you would say that you think
that's different Imperial gets soldiers
and I think is what they proposed right
I mean you think it's that the
difference would be utterly and not with
I mean that there are literally synonyms
yeah
and yet for whatever reason they when
you hear the word true but different
kind of cultural image comes to mind a
different kind of symbol comes to mind
versus when you hear the word soldier I
no idea why that's the case but we've
all it's almost as if we begun speaking
different languages depending on on
which cultural group we feel like we
belong to yeah
all right so final question to wrap this
all up I mean we could do we could do
this all day but I got two more
interviews so for all the people that
hear you that hear these ideas of
classical liberalism I'm thrilled that's
a little bit that I've been doing the
show these last couple years I feel like
the phrase classical liberalism has come
out a little bit you hear it now in
mainstream it's nice it's coming around
so for the people that want conversation
that want to not just impune their
intellectual opponents and that actually
want conversation all that stuff what's
the best method you're around a lot of
young people you're teaching this stuff
why is just because that I get tons of
email about this what do I do if I want
to be in the conversation and not
smeared and maligned and all that I'm f
what had the best way to march forward
but that's interesting actually and just
just based on the conversation that
we've had I mean I would say in some
sense to stay off of social media
because I mean at some level I mean
because it's some level classical
liberalism is it's a it's a difficult
doctrine as an individual I think I mean
that it says listen at some level you're
responsible for your own views at some
level you're responsible for exercising
individual judgment you aren't going to
be just sort of spoon-fed a series of
ideological signifiers that you can
Lance
to whenever you need them you're going
to have to do it you're going to read
you have to think you're going to have
to be the kind of person who's capable
of being responsible enough to be free
and so I would say you know yeah argue
all you want to debate all you want to
discuss how you want to but I would I
would do it in a way I would do it in
good faith I would assume that whoever
it is that you're talking to that they
have something to offer that they're
capable of changing their minds that
they're arguing with you in good faith
and that they aren't merely running
through a script of views that they
already hold or something like that and
that you assume the same position you
say I uh I could be wrong but the sort
of thing I haven't read everything I
haven't you know I there are limits to
my own understanding and I'm willing to
explore those limits so the burdens on a
burden well we got we got the word cut
out for us right I mean that's what I
mean that's what freedom at some level
is it's about I mean is that you as an
individual are responsible for making
your own way no I think that's a fitting
ending for this conversation for more on
professor Turner check out learn liberty
org slash speakers slash Brandon - turn
[Music]
you